[Applause]
thank you Malika to the city of Las
Vegas thank you so much for hosting the
Championships of our first ever inseason
tournament been a fantastic couple of
days here to the Laker organization Joey
to you your sister jeie Rob pinka
tremendous job coach ham thank you very
much to the Indiana Pacers thank you so
much herb Simon and your organization
you guys put on a great show we're
trying something a little new this year
we have some medals to so kids hand out
the
[Applause]
medals and now to the
Lakers kids we got something to do
[Applause]
here we have our first ever
NBA in season cup Laker team come take
your
[Applause]
trophy Joey
I'm going to start with you here because
this
franchise certainly is no stranger to
winning championships but now here for
the first ever NBA Cup victory what is
the feeling within this organization oh
my gosh it feels amazing to win the
first NBA cup of any team amazing I just
want to thank the fans who are here in
Vegas today all around the world in Los
Angeles thank you to our leaders jeie
the rest of of my family and Coach the
players the team the staff the employees
let's go
Lakers thank you so much and
congratulations speaking of head coach
Darin ham may I borrow you for a couple
of minutes
Darin
Darin in your first year as head coach
of this organization the team started
out 2 and 10 and spent much of the
Season crawling out from that place and
fast forward what does the momentum from
this inseason tournament win due for
this group I mean it's a huge shot in
the arm and you know we're thankful for
Mr Silver and the rest of the NBA brass
for coming up with this idea I think
it's a brilliant idea uh to infuse this
type of intensity and energy into the
season this early um we're totally
totally thankful and it it definitely
goes a long way in US continuing to
build our Rhythm to build our
cohesiveness and our continuity Darin
thank you so much and congratulations
thank you thank you and now please join
me in welcoming back NBA Commissioner
Adam Silver to present the 2023 inseason
tournament Most Valuable Player
award thank you and the last trophy the
MVP cup for outstanding play throughout
the entire tournament to a man who
frankly there's nothing else to win in
this league the only thing I can say I'm
sorry but it doesn't come with a
franchise
LeBron James the
[Applause]
MVP LeBron it has been clear from the
start of this tournament by both your
words and your play that you were
putting your full effort into this and
that set the standard for the rest of
the league why did you decide to put all
of this into something new uh cuz my
young is over here uh my rookies my
second year guys um some of them haveen
been experienced playoff
basketball uh some of their paychecks
are not as equipped as some of the older
guys on our team so and then some of our
fans during the December and January
months they start they kind of stall out
a little bit so I felt like it's my
obligation and it's my responsibility to
keep everybody engaged including my
teammates including our fans for our
beautiful sport so that's why I was
locked in from day one you certainly did
that I want to talk a little bit about
your teammate Anthony Davis another
dominant performance from him oh
absolutely I mean that was a sha like
dominant uh performance and we had the
big fell sitting down there by our by
our bench so I think 80 was expired um
40 20 multiple blocks multiple steals um
you know ad was just he was dominant big
time he was dominant Big Time LeBron you
you said this week that father time has
been undefeated thus far and you're
working to try to hand him that first
loss what is winning the first ever
inseason tournament MVP due to his
record uh yeah I don't think it's even
about the uh the MVP um I think it's
about us coming together and winning
this thing uh this is the inauguration
of the nend Season tournament it's
something like records will be broken uh
you know but one thing that would never
be broken is be the first to do
something and we're the first champions
of the nend Season tournament and nobody
can ever top that and it's great to be
able to do it with such a historical
franchise and it's even better to do it
with such a great great class of uh just
funny engaged competitive uh men over
here and they uh the first question they
asked me when I came off they was like
so when do we get our money I was like I
don't
know but I kind of do know but I'm not
going to tell him just yet lastly LeBron
before I let you you go you said
dominant for Anthony Davis but this has
been a dominant performance for your
entire team going 7 and0 in this
inseason tournament what does that tell
you about what this team is capable of
um I think we're we're just holding each
other accountable um the best thing
right now that we're starting to get
healthy um we we have a lot of length
and we have a lot of Defenders we have a
lot of guys that play unselfish
basketball and we have a lot of
competitors who want to compete every
single night so um you know just Big
Time Performance by our whole team to
get everybody back we're still missing
one of our top guys and Vincent and we
can't wait till he get back as well but
everybody has chipped in and uh we
wouldn't have been able to do it without
everybody that stepped on the floor and
everybody that didn't even play because
they had us going um as well on the
bench so it's all-around team effort
LeBron thank you and congratulations I
appreciate you
mik ladies and gentlemen one more time
for the inseason tournament MVP LeBron
James and the 20203 inseason tournament
champions the Los Angeles
Lakers
[Applause]
oh